how much are you willing to sacrifice I
have given up everything not everything
my lord we have located you since the
National all of them
I know what you fear Tanis the ring can
enslave the minds of man means hope to
our purpose no matter what becomes
unreal most let them be slaughtered like
my brothers at a black cake
we need to build our army
it's just a beginning
we do not start our Lord we will dictate
you fight you fight for the bright new
devilry is this I shoot God Joe Turner
to kill him too quickly
you ate
our
not with your shadow
he's perfect
[Music]
what you're faster
what's your business perfect
hi
froggy humiliate me he let your mark on
me buddy thing work to put my boring
dark I'll kill you on to this moment you
have not known suffering
alright enough of your mouth booze so
now I'm gonna kill you for all these
dogs to say always said you were an
optimist know what that is my it's about
sizing up a situation that's bloody
impossible and saying he all right I'll
have a go I'm exactly the same
I like him
kill the boss come on one in shadow
immortal we introduced a way to create
unique personal stories for every player
and in shadow of war we're expanding the
nemesis distances to new features we're
really excited about our forging an army
of followers and nemesis fortresses here
we use the Ring of Power and recruit
this Olaf Brewster chopper to expand our
army then we're going to adult a
fortress controlled by one of our odds
overlooked
oh that was not only a great a yokai to
skewer me that little swords good
vertical mighty well you're gonna need
more than that judge I made out nice one
Ranger
this never happened to baby
right Lord now bright Lord our Lord same
thing really
in results me ripping spines out which I
like to do anyway so either ways a win a
fine addition to our man nice birds from
your honor
odd will be your shadow no one gets to
you without my so don't worry about my
enemies it will all follow eventually
you want to apply your flag in Mordor
you'll need to do a deep there's a
fortress nearby
I said ruled by two-headed frog bridges
are Mountain deadly smart which long as
you have to be given the two aides
you've taken down you'll send a message
to Sauron and get yourselves on those
new gigs as part of the bargain we're
not going to do this alone gather your
troops will do just make sure you let me
pop his heads off won't ya
[Music]
so we already have a few loyal followers
in our army and recruiting booth means
we're ready to assault the fortress and
overthrow the overlord we're enormous
leox panning the open world of Mordor to
new regions like Sarah Goths and Kira
sundel models a massive living breathing
world filled with orc society tribes and
wildlife as well as stories and secrets
you could mean to any other Oracle have
died but I survived more than that I
thrived my brothers put me back together
stronger than ever but they didn't like
me into what I am you gate you created
the machine no machine he's trying to
get across Mordor seeking vengeance he's
one of the seven year old priority
he was bribed unitize through
you disorder distilling
instead of killing the machine will
dominate neither we can take advantage
of his abilities during the module
results you to girlcode'
before we charge headfirst into battle
we should plan our attack and select our
followers
[Music]
cool y'all know who whose rocket are you
[Music]
not Blake species a little rusty that's
not an icing would finally aspect the
heads of the case
he saved Reuben a toy horribly bad mark
on a black well I will handle the
Overlord you focus on the defenders to
find focus
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
close to you began range
[Music]
we bring this water
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
bow the right
you